in a previous video we talked about the
idea of ludonarrative dissonance a
situation where the story being told by
a game's mechanics disagrees with the
story being told by a games narrative
and people had a lot of interesting and
curious responses however one example
that people brought up stood out to me
because it demonstrated not a
misunderstanding of dissonance but
perhaps a misunderstanding of how games
interact with narrative structure so
let's talk about the Stanley parable
dark souls and intended play the Stanley
parable is a 2011 piece of first-person
interactive fiction that revolves around
a conflict between the player
protagonist Stanley and the game's
narrator as the player works Stanley
through the game the narrator exposes
his actions including immediately
upcoming actions that serve as
instructional when Stanley came to a set
of two of indoors the enter the dawn is
left the player chooses whether to
follow these instructions or to attempts
to subvert them in some way this was not
the correct way to the meeting room and
standing you in perfectly well Dark
Souls also published in 2011 is a
third-person role-playing game where the
player takes on the role of the chosen
undead a cursed human tasked by a vague
prophecy with rekindling the first flame
to preserve the age of fire now these
two games are all in all very different
from one another but they're ill astray
turf or our point here because they both
utilize elements of intentional
disobedience games have a dimension of
interaction that means there's not
merely intended interpretation but also
intended play the intended interaction
with a movie is pretty straightforward
the movie starts and you watch it
there are some subversive or alternative
forms of watching such as riffing a
movie or the sing-along or whatever the
hell midnight screenings of the room
count as
[Applause]
but generally speaking is pretty well
bounded this interaction in games means
that games can do something that other
media rarely can outside a very
experimental context which is to tell
the participant to do one thing while
expecting them to do another the Stanley
parable makes this process overt the
entire interaction paradigm of the game
more or less revolves around this single
principle which is what makes it so
illustrative but it's not actually a
niche type of interaction any open-world
game has a moment where the player is
told to do one thing and can then choose
to immediately turn around and go the
other direction opting instead to spend
dozens or even hundreds of hours doing
anything else but the thing that they
were asked to do some games address this
within the fiction such as the
Assassin's Creed games that suggests the
player is playing a somewhat scrambled
version of the stories events that while
Ezio may have jumped across all these
roofs he didn't necessarily do it for
five straight hours one afternoon
instead of stabbing miner Borges in the
neck
others like Final Fantasy 7 opted to
ignore the disconnect entirely operating
on the logic that it's only weird if you
call attention to it
games are constantly telling us to do
one thing and then waiting to see if we
actually do it the Stanley parable uses
this to create a conflict between the
player and the game but at the end of
the day that's just a costume put on an
otherwise ordinary interaction the
narrator is simply a disembodied
antagonist like show Dan or GLaDOS and
much like GLaDOS the narrator of the
Stanley parable tells you to do or not
do specific things while the game fully
expects you to ignore those requests
when you are done you will drop the
device in the equipment recovery in it
now those examples are all cases where a
character within the game issues
explicit instructions and it's pretty
clear that disobeying those instructions
is core to the game and possibly even
the plot doing what GLaDOS tells you to
do generally results in death but these
two operating layers still exist even in
less overt
games games are constantly telling us
through various cues how the game
expects us to behave in and interact
with its world this is encapsulated in
tutorials but also environmental
communication and reinforcing desired
play styles the Assassin's Creed games
are positively lousy with icons
indicators and things that blink and
glow to draw your eye and encourage
interaction it is a game series that
sits on the verge of screaming at you
about the many things it wants you to do
as is the case with Dark Souls the game
may simply use standard game language to
imply that you shouldn't behave in a
certain way that some NPCs you shouldn't
kill because they're your friends or
maybe just your allies or at the very
least just because they're not your
enemies these characters are friendly or
they sell you things so you should leave
them alone that the game says is the
correct way to behave but that's simply
a social contract between you and the
game simulacrum of friends and the game
absolutely intends for you to murder
every last one of them if you go on a
rampage in Dark Souls and kill every
last friendly NPC you will actually
unlock whole new side stories and
dungeons and bosses this is not simply
emergent or procedural this is intended
play if there is crafted content on the
other side of your misbehavior then it's
not actually misbehavior because it
turns out that murdering everyone is
also the correct way to behave
what a game intends for you to do
includes not only the things the fiction
of the game tells you to do but also the
broader things the game permits you to
do if there is something that the game's
author simply flat-out 100% did not want
you to experience did not want you to
engage in then it wouldn't be there even
when it comes to potential misbehavior
using the rules of the system you're
placed within externalities that they
didn't or couldn't account for like
throwing garbage at NPCs the only truly
accurate sign that the authors don't
want you doing that is that nothing
happens at all this is because even a
negative reaction even the game pushing
back against misbehavior is content this
is a big challenge when writing about
video games that the text of a game
includes not only the messages intended
and implied by the game's explicit plot
and the ideas reinforced by the
repetitive mechanical behaviors the game
utilizes but also a variety of
potentially dramatically diverging
intended postures of play a reading of
Dark Souls must encompass not just the
nominal story but also a breadth of
possibilities and how those
possibilities alter the reading this
added complexity means that games as
texts are harder to encompass but it
also means that games of the medium
provide a potentially far denser package
for meaning than other forms and I
understand why this trips people up this
idea that doing something the game is
telling you not to do is in fact what
the game wants you to do because it's
something the games authors have
accounted for and have programmed it to
respond to it's the treachery of images
but the treachery of content destined a
patina
so what do you think what's your
favorite moment in a game where it tells
you not to do something that it
ultimately intends for you to do and why
is it the genocide route in undertale
let me know in the comments
[Music]